OK, we are taking your calls for the
last time before 2021 via discord,
David Pakman dotcom discord.
Let's go down to our
friendly neighbors to the south in Miami.
Let's go to Akobo from Miami. You're on the air.
Hi, David. Oh, my God, I can't believe you just
I. I can't believe it. I can't believe so.
I'm like 16 years old. I'm from Miami.
I really like your show. Thank you.
And I want to know if you've said
if you've heard of the two thousand dollar
proposal that Donald Trump has talked about.
Yes, I mean, we did a whole segment about it
after the after Trump's weird four minute speech.
What's crazy is I agree with Trump. Two thousand
dollars would be a great number. And reminder, I'm
getting zero. This is not for me. I'm not trying
to get more money for myself. You understand?
Yeah, good.
The problem is, in the same speech,
Trump said Democrats have prevented anything
from happening for months. Democrats proposed
two thousand dollars six months ago and it went
nowhere because of Republicans. So I agree with
Trump in that I like the idea of two thousand
dollars, which was also brought up by Roxana. It
was also brought up by lots of other people. But
his four minute speech was just filled with lies.
Yeah, yeah, but I also saw that, like he was
mentioning that, like there should be stuff
taken out of the bill, like the like one of
the things that I saw was five hundred million
dollars for Israel or something. Right.
So so a couple of different things.
First of all, Trump didn't mention Israel.
Trump mentioned other countries. It's
also not true that Israel gets 500 million.
A lot of the countries that are listed,
there's money allocated, but it's really money
for American businesses, which a lot of people
don't understand. And in addition to that,
that stuff isn't in the covid bill. They did
two bills together. It was an omnibus where they
did the spending bill to keep government open and
they did the covid bill. So it's not even part
of the same bill. And then, like the third or
fourth lie in all of that is Trump criticized the
money that some countries are getting not from
the covid bill, but from the spending bill. But
Trump requested that they get that money months
ago when he put together his budget. So it's
like it's it's five or six layers of deception.
OK, OK, thank you. Thank you for clearing that up
for me, because I know I don't know that I did.
I mean, the lies are so intertwined that I
feel like it's hard to even explain them all.
Yeah, yeah. Because when he mentioned that,
like, I wouldn't think out of the kindness
of his heart at the end of his presidency
would give every American thousand dollars.
Your instinct is correct.
OK, well, thank you for taking my call.
All right. My pleasure. There is a 16
year old chocobo from Miami. I love it.